[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
michael k joining us how would you sum
up this rivalry in 2021 mike
uh pretty much even i mean if you look
at the numbers the red sox 110 out of
the 19 games they started off great the
yankees ended up great um and they swept
the red sox in the final series that
they played at fenway park and dan if
you think about it they need every
single one of those wins if they didn't
you know yesterday they would have been
playing in a tie breaking game with the
blue jays so i think they're fairly
evenly matched obviously the fan bases
don't like each other i don't know if
there's that much enmity between the
players
how good are these teams are either one
of these teams elite teams
well the yankees can be elite and they
can also be awful it's it's a hard team
to figure out there are times that they
look like they they can beat anybody and
they can easily win the world series and
then you know they end up losing eight
games to the baltimore orioles they're
very very tough to pin down and say
exactly what type of team they are uh
the red sox i think are better than
people thought they were going to be if
they don't have jd martinez today
because of the ankle maybe they're not
as good as you would think i think the
bullpen has been used a lot out of
necessity i'm not sure how much it's
there right now but this pitching
matchup between colin avaldi i think
it's a pretty even match up i think it's
a pretty even match up for for both
teams so it's definitely a flip of the
coin for sure
do you remember when you saw the yankees
change that they were going to go one
dimensional they were just going to be a
team that went up there and was trying
to hit home runs
i remember it was a couple of years ago
maybe five years ago that you know brian
cashman the yankee gm said something
like i'm looking for harry beast
now he's got one in the in you know the
broadcast booth but he wanted people out
actually on the field
so uh they just started piling you know
power hitters up there because they feel
the three true outcomes of the walk the
strikeout or home run that plays to
their strength and i'll tell you what
dan when they hit home runs they do they
do win but the problem is sometimes they
don't own runs and when they don't own
runs it's very very difficult for them
to to create runs although when they
were 35 and 11 that one streak you know
in the middle of the season they had
guys like andrew velasquez playing and
greg allen and they had to create runs
but they're back to the yankees right
now and they're going to hit a home run
or they're going to lose a game do you
think we'll get to the point where
somebody is counter-intuitive and that
they try to play small ball they're in a
maybe a pitcher's ballpark and and
that's their strength i always go back
to whitey herzog with those cardinals or
even you know kansas city royals that
they they couldn't compete but you can
find these players and if you build your
pitching staff in accordance to your
dimensions do you think we see that in
baseball at some point again
i hope i'm not sure but i hope uh as you
know dan sports is very copycat like so
if there's a team out there that
actually wins games like that i think
they might go that route but baseball is
so heavily analytic and they are not
doing this just on a whim
they've got computer readouts to say
this is the best the most effective way
to win games and until those readouts
say something else i think they'll still
keep stacking up home runs the thing
that i never understood dan i understand
the home runs win games i just don't
understand how they don't care about the
strikeouts and then you look like look
at a team like tampa bay they hit home
runs but they don't strike out and i
think that might be the next step
because what
their their excuse man is well nothing
bad can hit you know if you strike out
nothing bad could happen other than out
well nothing good could happen either i
mean you could put a ball in play and
there could be an error so i think that
tampa bay has solved that part of it
where you don't have to strike out 210
times
a year to hit 40 home runs i think
that's the next step i know we're
looking at the end result with the
match-ups for this one game format
is there a better format in your opinion
no matter who's in and you know the
dodgers won 106 and they're in a
one-game format that's not fair yankees
red sox why don't they play three and i
and as i said earlier in the show if
tampa bay was playing toronto no one
would be saying we got to have a three
game series it would be yeah let's just
get this one and done
is there a better format of fairer
format in your opinion
no i don't i don't think so it makes me
laugh but when people say you know it's
not fair to the dodgers really they knew
the rules of engagement finish out of
the giants you wouldn't have to play a
one game playoff the yankees and the red
sox soon as you head to the race you
wouldn't have to play a one-game wild
card i i actually like it they're highly
rated games essentially you've created
two game sevens win or go home and i
think that's what every sport wants to
do i think it's perfect and you know
there are teams that are going to be
left out and that's the beauty of it if
there weren't that this wasn't a wild
card situation it wouldn't be intense
down to the last inning on sunday and
one other thing dan if you turn this
into a best of three you are then
making it tougher and more difficult for
the team that won
the division because they've got to wait
longer and not play and sometimes that
takes you out of your game i think
you've got to pay a price if you're in
the wild card which the yankees and the
red sox will do because you're not going
to use coal in the first game of the
alds and you're not going to use zivaldi
in fact you can only use them once out
of the best of five you need that
detriment so that you go to win the
division i like it just the way it is
did you ever have one of those moments
phone calls meetings with george
steinbrenner in your career where you
went
oh boy
um
i know he was upset with me once um
because i said that the yankees had
reneged on a contract to daryl
strawberry and he was in the car writing
to the airport to leave new york and he
was listening to john and myself on the
radio and heard that and let's just put
it this way dan he made the driver turn
around on
stadium so we had a little bit of a
discussion after that game but usually
it was it was it was pretty cool because
you know we don't have to be homers with
the yankees we just say the truth
because that's how george steinberg was
if the team wasn't playing poorly he
said it so he allowed us to say it on
the air as well and it was kind of
refreshing
for somebody who didn't meet or didn't
know george steinbrenner how would you
sum him up
intense when he was in the building you
knew he was in the building even if you
didn't know he was there if you hadn't
seen him everybody was buttoned up and i
think that you still see the residual of
that with brian cashman who once told me
i overstudy everything simply because of
the fact i don't want him to ask me a
question that i don't know the answer to
so he was driven uh he had a really soft
side as well but he was very very
difficult to work for because if you
didn't do your job he didn't want you
there any longer that's that's the best
way i could describe him we got
daniel jones coming up would you rather
be a jets fan or a giants fan
well that's a hard question i i guess
the giants are closer so i would say i'd
rather be a giant fan although the jets
do have some hope because i think zach
wilson can play and i like robert sala
and how he's comported himself as well
but since i don't like suffering that
much stand at least not in sports uh i
think i would take the giants
can you see theo epstein coming to the
rescue for the new york mints
i can i guess the the offer could be
high enough that any reservations he
might have maybe working for steve cohen
i don't know why he would have those but
if he did you know steve cohen could
write a big enough check um i guess this
is the next thing to conquer you've
conquered chicago and boston and if you
could somehow straighten out the mets i
mean he's already got a plaque in
cooperstown anyway maybe they just build
him an entire wing if he did this
i wondered if he wanted to be the
commissioner though because he's working
in the commissioner's office and i i i
don't know what his end game is but i i
wondered about that that if he was sort
of
in the line of succession to take over
for rob manfred down down the road
you know i don't know if he would be uh
because the commissioner's job is more
businessman than sportsman and you know
obviously he's been the president of of
the cubs and obviously he ran some
business operations but you've got to
answer to 30 owners and and
amongst the owners is divisions and then
you've got to deal with the players as
well
i'm not sure he would want it and b
the owners are the guys that hire the
commissioner are they going to hire thea
theo epstein i'm not sure i think they
might go the businessman route again
what's the coolest thing in your office
um
right behind me is all these baseballs
and a couple of you know i had a lot of
announcer signs so ernie harwell and ben
scully uh and vince scully to me because
i went to fordham and he went to florida
he's kind of like the patron saint of
what we do even to this day so that's
that's one of my special things there
have you ever been mistaken for anybody
uh kiefer sutherland okay if you look at
my eye
i can see that
okay but uh he's a little better looking
than i am but i i also have gotten
lately um
jamison tyonne which i'm sorry for
jamison that you know people have to say
that about him
what about kurt schilling
oh yeah
i got that
i got that
guy comes up to me and said kurt i mean
it was unbelievable what you did in 2004
i said i didn't do anything in 2004.
and he goes no no no the whole bloody
sock thing i said that wasn't me and he
thought i was just blowing him off
so then i you know if he he insisted i
was kurt chilling so then i essentially
blew him off i said i don't really want
to talk to you
because it doesn't matter to you if this
guy doesn't like curt schilling
not at all but i mean i i get kurt
schilling a lot and as i go back more in
the power alleys
uh
have fun tonight there michael
i'm gonna try dan thanks a lot
michael k yankee play-by-play voice for
the s network and his book is my most
fascinating interviews from a-rod
to jay-z